this time I truly hate to say I told you
so
for months years at this point some of
us on the right have warned that liberal
Elites want to make us all eat bugs the
world economic Forum in particular has
pushed this
agendaags leave in zipad or nothing and
be happy
but lots of other people have done it
too Public Health figures celebrities
The Establishment media and many people
laughed this off as some sort of crazy
conspiracy
well what do you know
Europe is now officially eating the bugs
the European Union has officially
enacted a statute allowing food
producers to incorporate Cricket powder
into flower-based products
bread crackers cereal bars biscuits beer
like beverages chocolate soups sauces a
bunch of other items
they just grind up the Crickets guts and
excrement and all and then pack them
into your food now it is not exactly
mandatory
but it kind of is
because many if not most people are
going to end up eating bugs without even
knowing it
think about all the bizarre junk that is
already packed into your food seed oils
preservatives polysyllabic chemicals
that most people can't even pronounce
let alone identify
well now they're adding ground up
crickets and there isn't much most
people can do about it and not only are
the Crickets gross but some people might
be allergic to them some people might be
extremely allergic to them evidence on
allergic reactions has been inconclusive
according to the studies but the
political Elites don't care they're
going to go ahead with the plan anyway
no surprise there these are the same
sort of people who spent 22 years
pumping little kids full of puberty
blockers before thinking that maybe it
might be a good idea to test those
chemicals on animals that's what we
discussed yesterday on the show these
are the same people who pumped over five
and a half billion people with an
experimental drug on the promise that it
was safe and effective at stopping covid
neither of which claim was true
now they insist that everybody eat bugs
because the bugs are allegedly more
nutritionally efficient than grains and
meats and normal stuff
they claim it's better for the
environment we got to do it
but of course food is about more than
efficiency because human beings are more
than just meat sacks in need of calories
food is about taste tradition
ritual family food is one of the most
basic aspects of culture which is
precisely the reason the libs are so
eager to change it I'm Michael knowlesus
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from rust man who
says someone should let Stephen King
know that the Bible is banned in schools
so he can let all the kids know to run
out and read it it's true they always
want you to read the banned books but
only the gay porn stuff only the really
bad banned books whenever you point out
that some good books are banned in very
important places like public schools
then they say oh no never mind forget
about that no don't no don't read that
that's bad go read you gotta read the
gay porn it's very very important it's
hard to keep up you know when I want to
read anything for a long period of time
I need some energy so I got to check out
Black Rifle coffee right now go to Black
riflecoffee.com use promo code nulls
Black Rifle Coffee Company set out on a
mission to make the best cup of coffee
that ever could fill your mug they
wanted to sell enough premium coffee to
be able to build a support network for
veterans First Responders and law
enforcement thanks to your support that
dream has become a reality this year
alone your support has helped Black
Rifle coffee expand their team with
active duty service members veterans and
Veteran family members they were able to
donate over 120 000 bags of coffee to
Veterans and First Responders all thanks
to you if you want to continue
supporting this incredible company go to
Black riflecoffee.com use promo code
Knowles kwlas a checkout for 10 off your
first purchase and your first coffee
Club order Black Rifle coffee is roasted
by a veteran-led team of brilliant
coffee graders here in the U.S the
coffee is truly one of a kind but it's
your support that gets gear funding and
supplies into the hands of those honor
our front lines go to Black
riflecoffee.com use promo code knows for
10 off you can also find Black Rifle
coffee in grocery and convenience stores
near you Black Rifle coffee America's
coffee
people have misunderstood the bugs push
from the beginning
a lot of people didn't believe the bugs
thing would happen because bugs are
gross and nobody wants to eat them but
one they're not gonna just serve you
bugs right away they're going to grind
them up into little powder and just put
them into your cookies and your Breads
and not even probably tell you about it
or if they'll list it on the the
the ingredients list on the back and the
tiny font you're not going to know about
it in many cases
but then the other reason they said that
a lot of people have resisted this idea
that we're going to eat the bugs is they
say well
I don't know the bugs are such a taboo
in our culture sure other cultures
around the world eat bugs but we in the
west we don't do it
and so what the the libs they think it's
more nutritionally efficient they think
it's better for the environment so
they're going to try to make us eat bugs
despite how much eating bugs would
violate our taboos
that misses the point too
the libs are not trying to get us to eat
Z bugs despite the fact that that
violates our taboos they're they're
trying to get us to bugs precisely
because it violates our taboos
they're doing it because taboos and
standards and Norms Define culture and
the libs project is to completely upend
our culture and so the most direct way
to upend our culture is to reorder the
taboos and one of the most basic aspects
of culture is food
dude they're doing it because it's gross
doing it because it's gross and they're
going to wield power over you and
they're going to change the the very
definition of the culture that you hold
dear that they don't like speaking of
food a conservative commentator jono
Caldwell was just booted out of a
restaurant now jono happens to be black
was he booted out because he's black no
this isn't the Woolworths Lunch Counter
this isn't the 1950s or 60s no
was he booted out because he's
a man I don't think so now these days
men can go anywhere they can go to the
women's locker room then go to the
girl's bathroom no you know why he was
booted out he was booted out
because he's conservative
yesterday as we were having
um breakfast at this particular location
which I had never been to it was the
suggestion of them to visit this
particular place one of the owners came
over to the table and told us she had
been listening to our conversation we
were not welcome there and I said to her
I said did I say something that was
triggering to you she said no she said
our our politics aren't aligned I'm one
of the owners I'm an owner here I don't
feel comfortable you have to leave so
then I stood up I walked out and so did
the rest of my group she told me that I
needed to get out of her establishment
if this was not the Jim Crow South I
couldn't tell much of a difference Ron
DeSantis said in Florida discrimination
is it not allowed and I hope that
they're going to look closely to what
happened here at this restaurant
so he's booted out because he's
conservative a lot of people are asking
how is this legal well the reason it's
legal is there's no
civil rights protection for political
point of view
you can't go go to a court and say I was
discriminated against on the basis of my
political views it's not protected the
race is protected religion is protected
sex is protected sexual orientation and
gender identity in the wake of the
Bostock decision thank you Neil Gorsuch
that is protected
but political views are not
this is a reminder that
one of the one of the big stories about
the Civil Rights Revolution is not true
the big line about the Civil Rights
Revolution and you you might consider
this a positive you might consider this
a negative you might say Well it had
some good effects but it actually had
some bad effects too is that it gets rid
of freedom of Association as an
essential part of the American political
order prior to the Civil Rights
Revolution
if you didn't want to let somebody into
your store if you didn't want to let
somebody into your hotel you didn't have
you didn't want to let somebody to your
lunch counter you didn't have to do it
and in the 1960s people looked at that
and said oh that's kind of ugly because
some people are keeping black people out
of the lunch counters and that doesn't
seem right so so we're gonna we're gonna
get rid of that and uh most people said
okay that's a good thing but there's a
cost to everything in this world and so
when you get rid of freedom of
Association
you are maybe you're improving certain
social situations
but you might be
you might be eroding some of the
principles that all Americans hold very
dear
and you might not even be totally
getting rid of freedom of Association
right now
a a black guy can't be kicked out of a
lunch counter that's a good thing
but a black guy who's a conservative can
a conservative of any stripe can be
kicked out of a lunch counter
a
a white male
could be kicked out of a public
accommodation
it has been known to happen you saw this
especially during BLM and all the George
Floyd riots people saying this is a
black space white people not allowed
here you're seeing this crop up on
universities black only dorms
black only spaces white people not
allowed how's that legal well it's not
legal by the letter of the law but
nobody's going to enforce it
if any restaurant kicked out a lib you
know there would be a major lawsuit and
the litigant would probably win and the
way that they would win is they would
pretend that they were being booted out
for some other reason
be some lib you know with with purple
hair and crazy piercings and an antifa
shirt screaming about burning down The
Establishment you say hey lib can you
please get out of here this is you're
creating a nuisance and you know what
the live would say the lid would say
well you're only doing this because I'm
trans or I'm a lesbian or I'm this color
or I'm that race or I'm whatever and you
know that they would win because the
system is set up that way
where there are just two tracks here if
you if you attack anything that is
conservative traditional
pushing back against the cultural
revolution
you can and usually will be punished
if you're the one pushing that
Revolution
you're good you're safe we talked about
this yesterday when Stephen King It was
inveying against Banning books
and everyone seems to think that they're
against Banning books that's not true
we ban books in this culture we ban the
most important book we ban the Bible in
public schools
well that's different
we we kick people out of our lunch
counters
if they're conservative
the daily wire we were booted out of a
restaurant we had put a a deposit down
on this restaurant to have a dinner
before our company Christmas party
and then they found out who we were and
they said you're not welcome here
you got you guys are you because you're
conservative you're not allowed into the
restaurant and our protests are big
standing up against the man was Jeremy
and Ben and Drew and a friend of Candace
was there Spencer a number of us went in
uh afterward and just had a drink they
were too cowardly to actually kick us
out but this happens okay
this sort of thing happens this this
reordering of the political order it
didn't create justice for all
it it just created an opportunity to
attack conservatives of any race if any
of any geography of any of any kind of
background if they oppose the revolution
they're going down the revolution has
been televised and the revolution
can be communicated across all various
media
including phone to phone that's why you
got to check out pure talk right now
head on over to puretalk.com use promo
code and also if one of your goals this
year is to do business with companies
that share your beliefs then you got to
check out Pure Talk Pure Talk is the
antidote to woke wireless companies it
is proudly veteran-owned employs a
us-based customer service team and
absolutely refuses to spend money on
fake news networks not to mention Pure
Talk service is fantastic they are one
of the largest networks in the country
you can get blazing fast data at talk
and text for as low as 30 dollars a
month that's probably half of what
you're paying Verizon ATT or T-Mobile
switch over to puretalk in as little as
10 minutes while keeping your phone and
your phone number your first month is
guaranteed risk-free try it if you're
not completely happy with the service
you will get your money back this year
make it a goal to support companies that
support you go to puretalk.com and enter
promo code Knowles can Adobe Las to save
50 off your first month that is
puretalk.com promo code nulls kw-l-e-s
Pure Talk is simply
smarter
Wireless
speaking of bands
I have been banned by another University
you know every year I speak
at a number of college campuses I do
this with young Americas Foundation I've
done this for years at this point
and
if I got a little more time sometimes
I'll do I don't know I could do up to 10
schools a semester if I've got more work
here at DW they don't want to let me add
I'll do I'll at least do four or five
schools a semester
well I guess I'm doing one fewer this
year because Penn State
says that I'm not coming even though the
students invited me they submitted their
proposal to the school I actually didn't
know that I had been invited to Penn
State until after they told me that I
couldn't come this is a Penn State
University Harrisburg
they claim that they have the exclusive
right to deny a campus lecture from me
yours truly
they say any event considered
potentially harmful to the public image
of Penn State Harrisburg will be
rejected me they want to ban me whom
everybody loves so can you imagine that
shocking absolutely shocking this is
illegal Penn State is a public
university they have no right to do this
the students do have a right at this
public university to invite me to the
school and what they wanted me to speak
on is my book speechless controlling
words controlling Minds which is there
we go thank you number one National
bestseller very mainstream book it's a
book on the history and meaning of
language
not exactly a bomb throwing kind of
topic is it if anything it's a little
bit dry
they said no that's too much
this could harm the image
of the University
okay so so does Penn State have any
speakers come they do
who are some of the other speakers that
have come on campus recently that have
not harmed the public image of the
University well let's see we've got drag
bingo
student engagement office and student
government hosted drag Bingo they hosted
an lgbtq panel hosted by mix not Mr or
Mrs or miss mix Jacob Kelly who is a
queer inclusive sex educator that didn't
harm the public image of the University
they uh it's not even that they won't
have explicitly political events there
was a lecture by Amy Goodman of
democracy now which is a far left TV and
radio program that was totally fine so I
think I figured out what we're going to
do
I'm gonna we're gonna have to reapply I
mean I didn't apply at all it was the
students who applied on my behalf so if
they're listening right now what I want
you to do
I want you to just you change my
pronouns in the application you can
instead of Mr Michael Knowles you say
mix mix Michaela Michelle Knowles and
then I'll just show up there and I'll
wear some stilettos and I'll say this is
an inclusive event and then I can give
my lecture on the history of language
and I think then everybody will it'll
totally work out right
sounds great to me they're still keeping
this up
that's a public university
it's public university last year a
Catholic University banned me I had been
invited to St Thomas University in
Minnesota they Banned Me
because I espouse Catholic dogma that
doesn't I'm not joking
because I don't think that boys can
become girls because I hold to
unchangeable Catholic beliefs on a basic
question of human nature they said I'm
not welcome at the Catholic University
not only are we booted out of the weird
liberal private schools we're booted out
of
the nominally Catholic and conservative
schools and were booted out of public
accommodations expect more of that
expect if you haven't already expect to
be in John O Caldwell's position for the
daily wires position soon enough
freedom of Association
for them but not for us that's how it's
going to go and they are going to
ostracize us as as much as they can and
until conservatives recognize that it's
probably a little past time for us to
wield political power in in through the
same sort of processes that the left
wield political power albeit we should
do so in a just and moral way until we
recognize that as long as we just keep
saying well you know
come on this isn't fair look at this
double standard this is hypocrisy
imagine if the shoe were on the other
foot as long as we keep doing that we're
gonna lose and we're not going to get to
go to universities and which might be a
blessing in disguise and we're not going
to get to go to restaurants and we're
going to be forced to eat the bugs and
things are not going to turn out very
well at all speaking of Education
perfect timing on this story the story
is so delightful to me I mentioned
yesterday that chat GPT which is a very
mainstream AI artificial intelligence
program was able to get a pretty good
grade on a Wharton Business School exam
this is an exam from
probably the top business school in the
country and chat GPT was able to get a b
or a B minus on the exams so chat GPT
took some other exams they took a
medical license exam and the bar exam
to become a lawyer and chat GPT passed
got a passing score or a very close to
passing score on both tests
that was true on all three components of
the United States medical licensing exam
which is a test that Physicians holding
doctor of medicine degrees must pass for
medical licensure that the app passed it
without quote any specialized training
or reinforcement it also passed multiple
bar exams for different states humans
with seven years of post-secondary
education and bar exam specific training
we're able to get 68 of questions right
on these bar exams chat GPT which is
just a computer with no specific
training got 50.3 percent of the
questions right
and then if you looked at the top two or
three choices that that the model
selected for these questions they were
right 71 to 88 of the time
which which what that tells you is that
it's not just that the machine was
randomly guessing because 71 and 88 a
far surpasses the Baseline guessing rate
I love this I love this because it
contradicts the whole world economic
Forum Elite Davos line which is that in
the future all you useless people you
poor people you manufacturers you
service people you're you're going to be
useless we'll give you drugs and video
games you won't you don't you just go
away we'll pay you to go away we robots
are gonna do uh
it's not the waiters who are going to
get replaced by the robots it's you it's
it's the accountants it's the CFOs it's
the lawyers in many cases it's the it's
the white collar workers it's the middle
managers those are the people
who will in many cases be replaced but
not in all cases
and this is the other takeaway I think
from this
and it's a really important takeaway as
we think about artificial intelligence
which has proven itself much more
impressive than than even I thought it
would be the way that artificial
intelligence can render art
can render paintings and drawings and
images on some of the public programs
it's not extremely impressive on the on
the
private programs it's unbelievable as
some of my friends work in artificial
intelligence they've shown me some of
what they're working on the way that a
computer now can write a poem can can
paint a picture it is shocking and so
it's been very impressive
but that that doesn't mean it's the end
of the line for human beings and in fact
the the advances of AI I think show us
something really important about what it
means to be human because
are you going to hire
a robot to be your lawyer or to be your
doctor
in some cases maybe you would if you've
if you've just gotta write up a basic
legal document maybe you would get a
robot to do that if you just need a kind
of basic checkup or some some really
simple aspect of medicine maybe you
would have a robot do that
but when it comes to I don't know a
negotiation contract negotiations have
been in the news recently when it comes
to a contract negotiation when it comes
to establishing a legal framework for
your business when it comes to deciding
between one course of action for your
business or another or for a lawsuit or
for another when it comes to
sophisticated medical decisions that
require
real ethical consideration end of life
decisions
maybe decisions for children do you get
vaccinated do you not get vaccinated do
you have this procedure do you know you
probably don't want a robot making those
decisions
and and the reason for that is that law
and Medicine are not just about facts
and science
the the libs want us to believe
that everything is just about facts
facts and Science and statistics and and
the whole world if we just we just got
to plug the whole world into a computer
it'll make all our decisions for us and
then we can just lie back and do nothing
but no there is more to life than facts
there's more to life much more to life
than science
you hear me say it on the show a lot
statistics are fake statistics are at
least 175 percent of Statistics are
completely made up and ridiculous and
pointless even when it comes to the law
conservatives have fallen into this
facts only science only scientistic view
of the world but it's a mistake you see
this in in the obsession with textualism
and originalism in law
all of which derive from legal
positivism this obsession with just the
ink on the paper of a statute but that's
not all there is to the law
there is there is the Lex of the law
there is the the statute as it's written
and the Constitution as it's written but
then there is the use you know to use
the Latin then there is the
the background principles of the law
then there is the natural law then there
is our moral intuition then there is the
fact that judges are Judges precisely
for their judgment to apply prudence and
wisdom that doctors are supposed to have
a bedside Manner and are supposed to use
their judgment and they have to take
ethics courses they don't take nearly
enough ethics courses
that there is a human component here
that
necessarily is missing from a computer
that it's not it's not all you can't
just plug life into a computer and
expect a perfect outcome at the end life
is too chaotic and complex and and
Transcendent of merely physical
scientistic considerations there's
there's more to life than just atoms and
facts
speaking of transcending scientism
middle-aged white guys are killing
themselves at a very high rate at an
increasingly High rate
we've talked about this for years this
is Led in in a large part to the decline
in the American life expectancy
we've had several years in recent memory
where the life expectancy has decreased
this really just started for the first
time not not that long ago
why because of debts of despair
among middle-aged white Americans
well now there's a study
it's a new study and so you know when
there's a study then we can finally
believe it
there's a study out
that shows that a major driver of these
deaths of Despair for middle-aged white
guys is loss of religion
in other words there's now a scientific
study
to prove what normal people have
intuited the whole time what anybody
with two brain cells and any even iota
of Common Sense has known from the very
beginning
foreign
you despair because despair
means a loss of Hope
shocking but stop the presses this paper
was just circulated by the National
Bureau of economic research found that
the increase in deaths of Despair among
middle-aged white Americans which
started in the early 90s was the
aftermath of a declining religiosity in
the United States specifically by the
same group it's true that religion in
general has declined but especially for
these now middle-aged white guys they
left the church in very large numbers
you might be able to think of your own
memories depending on how you were
raised of maybe you went to church as a
kid maybe you didn't
and even if you did did daddy always go
to church
I bet in a lot of cases it was just
mommy took the kids to church and daddy
stayed home and watched football
that that phenomenon exploded over the
last 30 years
why did this happen why did this group
leave the church
I think in large part that group left
the church because of supposed reforms
of the churches that went on during the
1960s you saw this you certainly saw
this in the mainline Protestant churches
which at this point are basically like
LGBT far left morning tea hour I think
of the poor episcopalians or the
methodists have gone completely and
certain shades of Presbyterians have
gone completely over the edge you saw
this in the Catholic church too even
with the weight of 2000 years of inertia
and the magisterium and and divine
institutions and certainly in my view
even then you saw in the wake of the
second Vatican Council liturgical
deformations that that
made even the Holy Mass
kind of effeminate and shallow
much more shallow than the tradition you
you
completely change the orientation of the
mass you you now have the priest facing
away from the altar facing the people
frequently telling jokes as a priest
friend of mine once described telling
jokes like a ham actor in a dying
Vaudeville show who would do well to
limit his repertoire to the the little
barbs that Saint John told the Blessed
Mother while her son bled on the cross
I think it drives the point home pretty
well you replaced beautiful singing and
serious chanting and elevating music
with a bunch of mariachi bands and these
lame insipid ditties from the 1970s that
weren't even cool 50 years ago
and then you expect a man to go there a
man who had previously been singing good
old proper hymns Good Old English hymns
or or older chanting and then he goes
there and he's got he's got to sing
these 70s songs I Will Raise You Up On
Eagle's Wings and it's just so lame and
the only people that that kind of
defamation appeals to are
squishes and Libs and women you know and
and only a specific subset of women who
who
do not speak to a traditional and
certainly not to a masculine culture so
for these reasons and more men leave the
church and now they're they're depressed
and killing themselves there's a
political aspect to this as well though
this group of economists looked at the
impact of blue laws across the country
and how the increased repeal of blue
laws
are followed by a loss in church
attendance and an increased
secularization so we all agree I think
we could even if you're an atheist or an
agnostic you don't go to church you can
it's very easy for people to see how a
change in the culture of the church
can lead people to leave the church
what's a little harder for people to
accept is how political changes changes
in the government and the political
order even outside of the church
can drive this sort of thing but it does
as I have
tried to make clear for years
politics is Downstream of culture sure
that's true movies and songs and
rituals and things certainly affect the
kind of laws that we're going to pass
but I do find that phrase to be a little
bit of a Libertarian cope and an excuse
not to engage in the political order not
to wield just political power on the
happy occasions that people give it to
us because politics
though Downstream of culture in some
ways
politics can also lead the culture
culture can be Downstream of Politics as
well
East Germany is atheist today West
Germany is mostly religious though of a
kind of confused religiosity
nevertheless more than half of West
Germans would call themselves religious
why is that is that because of regional
variations in bratwurst no it's because
Godless communism was the dominant
regime in East Germany for much of the
last century
and even after the Berlin Wall falls
down there are after effects of that
from the political order onto the
culture
so what do we do about it
I think we've got to take on both issues
yes well at a personal level yes we
should work on our own inner spiritual
life of course I'm not I don't mean to
diminish that and then from the cultural
level
cult referring to Cults referring even
at a deep level to religion we need to
reform the churches so that they are
more
serious and reverent and conducive to
men going to church
and we've got to change the political
order such that the incentives in the
culture in our political order are to
go to church or to have belief or to
have hope or to be good citizens are to
perform acts of charity for one another
are oriented toward the common good
there's no neutrality here the
government is always going to be
creating incentives and disincentives to
different actions
for all of American History we had
incentives toward all of those good
things
and disincentives toward the opposite we
had we had blue laws we had we had laws
against adultery we had blasphemy laws
for goodness sakes okay so don't tell me
that it's out of the American tradition
to take these kinds of issues seriously
that is the American tradition but now
what do we have we don't have a neutral
political order now we've just got
incentives for all the opposite stuff
we've got incentives for people to leave
their families we've got incentives for
people to do a bunch of drugs and get
involved in weird sex stuff and and
ignore the common good and only pursue
their own selfish interests we've got
interest we've got incentives for that
on the left and the right we've got it
throughout the whole culture we've got
incentives for during the covid
lockdowns we shut down the churches we
keep the pot dispensaries open in
California
okay those those are completely skewed
incentives and disincentives and they're
it's having real effects I I know that
a lot of people who are a little a
little more skeptical of religion or
they just that's religion's not their
thing they say oh you know Michael come
on who cares we've got bigger issues to
talk about
do you think there's a bigger political
issue than Americans dying than the
average life expectancy decreasing that
a huge group of Americans middle-aged
white guys just killing themselves and
oding on drugs because of a loss of Hope
is there any bigger political issue
then the loss of Hope
then the loss of faith and the loss of
Charity love philia Central to any
political order is that I don't think
there's anything I don't think tax rates
are a bigger issue than that I don't
think deregulation is a bigger issue
than that
I don't I don't I don't think
immigration is a bigger issue
immigration is a big issue
the the loss of
faith hope and charity that
it's kind of the whole game and I think
we ought to pay a little bit more
attention to it
speaking of middle-aged white men
a couple of middle-aged white men just
lost their jobs and that's a good thing
generally it's bad when middle-aged
white guys lose their jobs in America
but this time it's pretty good
Adam Schiff and Eric swalwell just lost
their jobs on the house intelligence
committee this because the Republicans
took over the house Kevin McCarthy's The
Speaker of the House Kevin McCarthy said
listen jerks both of you guys are off
the Intel committee you shouldn't have
security clearances you shouldn't be
around any kind of sensitive information
uh Schiff you're a liar who who has
mishandled classified information for
the entire Trump presidency and swalwell
you were doing weird stuff with the
Chinese spy so neither of you guys can
be trusted
Hakeem Jeffries who's the Democrat
minority leader in the house he came out
he said this is a a shocking upsetting
of precedent you can't do this that the
tradition the precedent in the house is
that the minority party gets to name the
people that it wants to the Committees
and then the speaker of the house is
supposed to accept that
this is awful he says it's my
understanding that you intend to break
with the long-standing house tradition
of deference to the minority party
you you were you should honor past
practice
I'm glad to hear Hakeem Jeffries and the
libs mention honoring past practice
for once in their entire lives
is this Ring's so Hollow do the libs
honor anything about the Pat the libs
hate the past the lips spend all their
time tearing down statues of the past
and talking about how evil the past was
and how anything that is traditional or
conservative is just terrible and we
need to upend the whole thing
except for this except for Adam Schiff
and Eric swalwell staying on the Intel
committee that that's just that's the
one historical precedent that we need to
keep I don't think so
I think this is chickens coming home to
roost is what I think this is and I
think that when
the Democrats when Pelosi set up the
Preposterous January 6 committee
to investigate the worst thing that ever
happened in American history and and the
Republicans said okay we're going to
send some Republicans to this committee
then we're going to name Jim Jordan I
forget who the other uh Republican
Congressman who's going to go to that
committee were the
the house said nope
Pelosi said no you're not going to do
that we're not going to let you have any
actual Republicans we're going to name
the Republicans it's going to be it's
going to be Liz Cheney and Adam
kinzinger who aren't real Republicans
who are for all intents and purposes
Democrats
oh but now this is the great upsetting
of oh no this is terrible okay well I
guess Hakeem Jeffries just made a slight
Progressive out of me because I think
that's one historical tradition that
that's gone and even if it was a good
tradition the Democrats are the ones who
blew it up and now I don't want to hear
them whining about the chickens coming
home to roost this month we are
celebrating the anniversary of one of
the greatest moments in Daily wire
history after months of us leading the
legal battle against the federal
government and a national do not comply
campaign
the Supreme Court ruled in our favor and
blocked the Biden administration's
outrageous vaccine mandate this mandate
would have set a dangerous precedent
giving the unelected OSHA power over the
personal medical decisions of Americans
the Supreme Court recognized this gross
power grab and made the right decision
we are so proud to have led the charge
in this fight
could not have done that without you
thousands of you joined the daily wire
and over a million Americans signed our
petition
against the mandates to celebrate we're
offering 40 off our annual memberships
with the code do not comply so celebrate
one of the greatest moments in Daily
wire history with 40 percent off your
annual membership daily wire.com
subscribe join the winning team as we
continue to crush the libs do not comply
is the code do not comply for 40 percent
off
speaking of committees
Republican Congressman Marjorie Taylor
green
is set to get new committee positions
this is a big comeback for MTG because
she had previously been kicked off of
the Committees
now
the GOP house steering committee voted
to give Marjorie a seat on the house
Homeland Security committee this is a
minor Personnel issue so I don't want to
spend too much time on it but
it's an important one because it shows
you how politics works
the the nitty-gritty nuts and bolts of
Politics the reason that Marjorie made a
comeback is because she backed Kevin
McCarthy
and she backed Kevin McCarthy in that
house fight
over her fellow conservatives in the
freedom caucus who were opposing
McCarthy
and it was it was a real tough fight
here and a lot of people wondered they
said why is Marjorie Taylor Greene who
is one of the more conservative members
of the House certainly one of the more
outspoken conservatives why is she
backing a guy who's who's being called
establishment
this is why
because it was the only way that she
could get any even marginal power back
in the House of Representatives
and some people have attacked her for it
and said well that's unprincipled
but I don't know that it's totally
unprincipled Kevin McCarthy was likely
going to win anyway she realized this
was her only path back
now she's on a committee
I I'm almost certain Kevin McCarthy said
the only way that you were getting on a
committee ever again is by backing me
and whipping some votes for me
and it brings me back to a principle
that old cocaine Mitch McConnell love
him or hate him he made a very good
point
he said the way politics works is
the winners go and make laws and the
losers go home
[Music]
say hello to my little friend that's
what he said he said at least the first
part is what he said and that's true
that's how politics works
now Marjorie green she's got a little
bit of power back hope she uses it well
I trust that she will use it well
speaking of inclusion
Facebook has decided to lift a ban that
it had had for some years now on the
azov regiment the asov regiment is a
military regiment in Ukraine
uh that has a bunch of Nazis in it
and when I when I say it has a bunch of
Nazis in it I I I'm using that term in
at least a slightly more precise way
than the libs do when they call all of
us Nazis
it's a it's a battalion that uses Nazi
symbols and signs and where is Nazi
symbols on their uniforms and so because
of this they had been kicked off of
Facebook in fact the azov regiment is is
one of the justifications that Putin
made in his initial speech outlining the
the reason for the war in Ukraine he
said we're going to go in and de-notsify
Ukraine and in in the western press they
reported this and said this is a
completely baseless charge no it there
is a basis for this charge the basis is
the Azo regiment which does use Nazi
like symbols and signs
so and Facebook had kicked the azov
regimen off because of this Nazi
Association but now they've lifted that
ban because Facebook supports Ukraine
against Russia and so all of a sudden
the Nazis aren't so Nazi anymore and
they get to go into Facebook
all of which I mentioned not to say
anything about the war in Ukraine not to
say anything about Russia or
zielinski or the American side because
we are we are essentially fighting this
war with Russian we're just using
Ukraine as a proxy
I mention it because it shows you that
political alliances are circumstantial
not eternal
let's not forget in the Second World War
we teamed up with
the Communists we teamed up with Stalin
one of the worst Communists ever a truly
evil evil empire
and we created an alliance with them to
defeat Hitler and Nazi Germany
and then immediately after the war then
we fight a decades-long war with the
Soviet Union the Cold War I mentioned
this to show
that even the meaning of a word like
Nazi
is constantly in flux three days ago the
azov regiment with a bunch of Nazis
today oh they're not Nazis at all that's
right that's propaganda you're a Putin
apologist if you say that well hold on
five days ago you were the ones telling
me that they were Nazis yeah no forget
that pay no attention to the man behind
the curtain these are not the dreads
you're looking for they're not Nazis
you're a Nazi
no you're a Nazi no you're a Nazi the
word Nazi is in flux
because there are no Nazis anymore
the Nazis are over
Nazis refer to a specific political
movement in a specific place at a
specific time
in the 20th century in Europe
it doesn't if you even at the same time
if you were to call Italians Nazis
followers of Mussolini Nazis that is not
true they were not Nazis they were
fascists but they weren't Nazis
do you call the followers of Francisco
Franco not that's not true they were not
Nazis they were right-wing they were
authoritarian they were not Nazis that
refers to a specific thing and the the
fact that the Nazis are gone and there
are no Nazis anymore and there cannot be
Nazis anymore is the reason that this
word can be in flux because now that it
has the specific referent is gone it can
mean anything at all
and it will mean all manner of things
yes they call you a Nazi today
they call Benin Nazi they call it
Shapiro
a man who wears a yamaka every day of
his life they call him a Nazi
they call all sorts of people not
because it is just a word that is in
flux the azov regiment used to be Nazis
today they're not Nazis they will be
Nazis again at some point mark my words
speaking of warfare
the libs are trying to ban our guns they
specifically are trying to ban AR-15s
you're saying a big move among the house
Democrats to ban the AR-15 one of the
most popular guns in the country
and their arguments are not totally
persuasive Nina Turner who is some lady
from The Young Turks
she typified a left-wing argument
against the AR-15 she said
if you need an AR-15 to hunt
you're probably not a great hunter
I promise you this is a woman who has
never handled an AR-15 she's probably
never seen an AR-15 in person she has no
idea how the Gun Works what kind of
caliber round it takes she doesn't know
anything about it
as is true of almost all of the labs
including the libs who are writing the
laws on guns
for starters you can hunt with an AR-15
but an AR-15 would not be a wise choice
for lots of hunting
if you're hunting small deer or you're
hunting rabbits AR-15 fine choice if
you're hunting a bear
if you're hunting a lion hunting an
elephant I would not recommend the AR-15
I don't think that is going to end very
well for you
but this argument is not really even an
argument it's it's a moving of the goal
posts in in the way that the libs always
move the goal posts
I know they're not Nina Turner and the
libs are not making this argument
the AR-15 is the worst most lethal most
powerful gun ever made it's not it's
obviously not that's why sure you can
hunt some deer with the AR-15 but you
would want a much more powerful weapon
to hunt something like a bear or a or a
bigger animal so they're not making that
argument they can't make the argument
that the AR-15 is totally completely
different from any other bolt action 223
rifle they they or or
or even not even a semi-automatic rifle
that is not an AR-15 or they can't they
can't make these distinctions so they
don't so what do they say it's this kind
of snide remark
oh you know you're probably just not a
good Hunter they did this with torture
do you remember during the debates on
torture and enhanced interrogation
during the bush years the the libs said
torture is terrible it's cruel and
unusual punishment
the argument against that would be well
no it's not
it's not a it's not all that unusual and
it's not punishment torture here is in
the American Experience of the war in
Iraq was to get information out of
people
the internet Scalia made this point he
said when you're when you're torturing
someone to get information out of them
you're not punishing that person
you're it probably doesn't feel that
great but you're not you're not actually
punishing them they say well but torture
it's torturing uh foreign combatants
that's against the law by the Geneva
conventions no not really not when
you're talking about terrorists so point
of the Geneva Convention protections is
to protect civilians in times of War so
if a if a if you extend Geneva
Convention protections to terrorists who
specifically Target civilians you
undermine the entire Geneva conventions
okay well no but the well you know what
I say torture just doesn't work
it doesn't it's evil and terrible and it
doesn't even work well hold on maybe
that's a that's just a separate point so
which is it
is the problem that it doesn't work or
is the problem that it's evil and cruel
and unusual punishment they don't have
an answer to it so they're just trying
to throw spaghetti at the wall they're
uh speaking of the law you remember
during the controversy over the wall
during Trump they said my problem with
the Trump wall is that it's evil and
it's inhumane and it doesn't work
if it's evil and inhumane presumably
that is because it works because it's
evil and inhumane to keep the illegal
aliens out or it's evil and inhumane to
make them try to crawl up a wall and
that's very dangerous or is
or it doesn't work but it if it doesn't
work it's not evil and inhumane because
it doesn't do anything you just get
right across that's what they're doing
on the guns it shows you how little
argument they have they might still ban
them anyway
they're going to do their best to ban
them anyway but they're not not going to
ban them by persuading you they're going
to ban them in the same way they're
going to get you to eat the bugs they're
just going to do it
outside of the realm of public debate
they're just going to do it because they
have the power and they're willing to
wield it
you know what today is today is woke
Wednesday the rest of the show continues
now
there is a very
uh thought-provoking woke reaction that
Mr Davies and the other producers want
me to
to process give my expert analysis on
you only get that on the member segment
so to become a member today use code
Knowles to check out kwles that's
dailywire.com
use code nulls you will get two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]
uh
foreign